it's infrastructure week which means a
lot of stuff is happening that has
nothing to do with infrastructure
michael avenatti is probably going to
prison and Quentin Tarantino stands up
for himself I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
venture Pierrot show the news cycle
grows ever more ridiculous and you'll
get to all of it but first in quarter
one gold purchases by central banks were
the highest in six years I'll bet you
did not know that considering how good
the economy is but in the face of the
dollars declining stature what exactly
are you doing to protect your savings
become your own central bank move some
of your savings to gold can you afford
another hit to your retirement like the
last downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
hedge against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals some of the economic
indicators are looking a little volatile
these days Gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be -
doesn't mean take all your money and
stick it under the mattress it means you
should have some money in precious
metals the company I trust with precious
metal purchases is Birch gold group
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can even move that IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which could be
good for people who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from future geopolitical uncertainty
look back historically when the bottom
falls out of everything else gold does
tend to safeguard savings it has never
been worth zero Birch gold group are the
folks i trust they have thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews contacts Birch gold group get a
free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you go
check them out right now and if you want
that no obligation kept there's a 16
page kit text Ben - 47 47 47 again text
Ben my name - 47 47 47 for that no cost
free of obligation 16 page comprehensive
kit about whether to invest in gold or
not check it out
text Ben - 47 47 47 and talks my friends
at Birch called already so yesterday the
big news obviously was that President
Trump had a big blowup with Nancy Pelosi
this all this all sort of launched with
Nancy Pelosi accusing president Trump of
engaging in a cover-up preemptively
now she's still not clear exactly what
it is that Trump is covering up and this
is the part that nobody seems willing to
discuss what exactly is from covering up
so Trump obviously doesn't want to
cooperate with Congress because he's
ticked off that they won't leave him
alone maybe he wants to cover up
presumably
his finances maybe he just doesn't want
them digging into his personal affairs
but they have actually not accused him
of any criminal activity they can't
explain what it is he is trying to cover
up at this point at least in Watergate
you knew what Nixon was trying to cover
up he was trying to cover up whether or
not he knew about the Watergate break-in
and that was the cover-up the cover-up
was of a crime what is the crime the
Democrats are accusing President Trump
of we've already had the Mallo report
Mulla report concluded with no crime no
finding of criminal activity and
Democrats are still accusing Trump of
engaging in a cover-up now maybe he's
trying as I say to cover-up material
that is non criminal in nature but that
is not a quote unquote cover-up that is
him just trying to not disclose to the
public stuff that is embarrassing so
it's a cover-up in sort of a colloquial
sense but in the legal sense it's not a
cover-up normally when people say
something is a cover-up what they mean
is that you are covering for illegal
activity but if I don't want you to know
what I got my wife for her birthday and
you subpoena information about that and
I say no I suppose that's a cover-up but
not really in the way that the Democrats
mean it here's Nancy Pelosi accusing
Trump of engaging in a cover-up without
actually alleging a crime respectful
sharing of ideas and I think their
impressive presentation by our chairs we
do believe that it's important for the
to follow the facts we believe that no
one is above the law including the
President of the United States and we
believe that the President of the United
States is engaged in a cover-up in a
cover-up and that may create you okay so
this set off President Trump she accused
Trump of engaging in a cover-up right
before she headed off to the White House
and she played this effectively as well
as she could because what she did was
she set Trump off which was her goal and
the goal of somebody like Pelosi who's
trying to troll Trump is to make Trump
look as though he's volatile as I said a
couple of days ago on the show the
Democratic strategy for 2020 is not to
suggest that America is going badly
because America isn't really going badly
the economy is going pretty well we
don't have any serious foreign crises on
the horizon all of that is true so
instead what they have to do is paint
president Trump is uniquely volatile
that is a fruitful line of attack
because the president on a personal
level does happen to be a volatile
individual and so the sole goal of
Democrats from now until 2020 is going
to
make Trump look as unpredictable as
possible to make people feel disquieted
with him to make him look as though he
is reacting in extreme fashion to things
and that's exactly what they
accomplished yesterday so Trump walks
into a meeting supposedly about
infrastructure and then he walks right
out he says he apparently told the
members of the meeting that he was not
interested in negotiating with them on
infrastructure so long as they were
trying to investigate him for the
possibility of impeachment
apparently he walked in according to a
White House official he walked into the
Cabinet Room and Nancy Pelosi was there
and so was Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer I've never understood exactly
why Trump is having these meetings with
Schumer and Pelosi why not just have the
meeting with Pelosi and Mitch McConnell
Mitch McConnell is a clever politician
who will be able to provide the
opposition necessary to Pelosi without
Trump actually having to do it himself
it makes more sense if you're
negotiating an infrastructure bill to
have you know the heads of the various
of the various branches of the
legislature you want the head of the
house and the head of the Senate not the
Democratic head of the House and the
Democratic head of the Democratic Party
in the Senate which is a minority in any
case Trump walks into this meeting and
according to CNBC have fective Lee said
to the visiting Democrats he wanted to
do infrastructure quote but quote you're
focusing on investigating when you're
done we can talk meeting over
and then Trump walked out onto the lawn
over at the Rose Garden and he had a
podium that was fixed up with a placard
that said on it 35 million dollars spent
two thousand interviews 18 angry
Democrats no collusion no obstruction
you had this I kid you not
pasted it on the front of the boat which
is really great I mean it looked it
looked like something out of real a
fortune I mean it was it was a bob
barker move by President Trump so the
president gets up behind that podium
supposedly spontaneously and then
proceeds to rip into the Democrats Nancy
Pelosi just before our meeting made a
statement that we believe that the
President of the United States is
engaged in a cover-up well it turns out
I'm the most and I think most of you
would agree to this I'm the most
transparent president probably in the
history of this country things are going
well and I said let's have the meeting
on infrastructure we'll get that done
easy
that's one of the easy ones and instead
of walking in happily into a meeting I
walk in to look at people that had just
said that I was doing a cover-up I don't
do cover-ups you people know that
probably better than anybody my favorite
part of this particular quote from
President Trump seemed appealing to the
media who hate his guts you guys know
better than anybody that I'm super
transparent yeah those media members
those are not your friends as president
Trump obviously knows and when he says
that that he doesn't engage in cover-ups
I mean we do have a sign check like from
you too stormy Daniels so there is of
that but but that's not the kind of
cover-up that Nancy Pelosi is talking
about what he means is I'm not covering
up for any criminal activity and there's
no evidence that I am which is obviously
true to this to this point I mean we've
seen no evidence of actual criminal
activity at this point in time so people
on the right are saying that President
Trump was right to do this that he's
right to walk out I think it's
justifiable for him to walk out I'm not
sure that it is the smartest move for
him to walk out as an aficionado of
walkouts I can say that I think that the
President of the United States he has a
case here and an emotional case here I
don't know that it is his best play the
reason I say that is because right now
if you look at the polling data
President Trump is not popular enough to
be re-elected I mean just by polling
data he needs to raise his numbers he
could be reelected in spite of the
polling data he did pull a rabbit out of
hell last time but these are not good
numbers for an incumbent president
there's a new poll for Monmouth
University released on Wednesday it
found that only 37% of voters believe
that President Trump should be reelected
fully 60% say they think it's time to
have somebody new in the White House
that is the highest percentage of voters
saying they're eager for a change since
Monmouth first began asking the question
last November his approval rating is
currently at 40 percent positive 52
percent negative that is at the low end
of his approval ratings for the past 12
months the poll also found deep
pessimism about the direction of the
country 29 percent of respondents saying
the u.s. is on the right track
sixty-three percent saying it was headed
in the wrong direction
those are astonishing numbers given the
fact that the economy is this good 56%
of voters however say the president
Trump should not be impeached and
compelled to leave office 39% support
impeachment and removal so here is
where we are and is a weird political
situation what Democrats want to do is
not impeach him but to continue people
feeling really uncomfortable Trump so
anything that exacerbates that feeling
of discomfort with President Trump is
what Democrats are going to push at this
point short of impeachment they don't
want to impeach him because they feel
like he's easier to beat in an election
than to effectively impeach I mean it'll
get to the Senate he's not going
anywhere according to polls most
Americans what the end of these of the
of the Russia investigation so 53% of
Americans say that we should drop these
investigations on Russia and move on to
other issues but in 58 percent of
Americans feel like they've heard enough
about the Muller report but among
Democrats 95 percent of Democrats say
that the Trump administration should
coordinate and cooperate with the
congressional investigation 77 percent
of independents say that the president
should fifty four percent of Republicans
say that he should so in other words the
the American people are our split they
do not want impeachment they're not
super interested in the investigations
but they also don't want to see the
president appear to be stonewalling and
so the president's best move here is to
sure protest that this is a giant waste
of time but for him to play above the
fray would actually be in his benefit
right now it would be politically
beneficial for the President of the
United States instead of walking out of
negotiations on infrastructure it would
be politically beneficial for him to sit
down and and simply say in front of
cameras you should open it up you should
you should open it up in front of the
cameras you should say listen Nancy
you've been saying some very nasty and
unjustified things about me you don't
have evidence that I've done anything
criminal you yourself have said that
you're not interested in impeaching me
so this is all politically motivated
stuff now let's go let's get down to
business and let's do infrastructure
right that would be the way to do this
instead it now appears that the
president is holding infrastructure
hostage in order to get them to an to
end investigations into him personally
which is exactly what Democrats wanted
him to do I think that the President did
politically walk into a trap after
thinking about this for 24 hours again I
have a lot of sympathy for the president
here the president was ambushed by
Democrats there is no question and on an
emotional level I get it I get him
saying listen I'm not working with you
guys you're jerks out totally get that
on a political level it would be better
for the president for him to walk in
better for
for him to walk in and say the Democrats
listen you guys are being jerks you guys
are being terrible you're driving all of
this partisan political nonsense I'm
gonna try to work with you anyway
because that's how magnanimous
I am magnanimity magnanimity in the face
of cruelty is very often a winning
political strategy we'll get some more
of this in just a second first I need to
talk to you about one of my favorite
companies the u.s. concealed-carry
Association the u.s. CCA it's an
organization that helps educate train
and legally protect responsibly armed
Americans they truly stand up for the
rights of citizens like you and like me
their work helps make sure that this
country will always stay free and safe
if you want to find out more just text
the word win - 87 - 2 - right now
there's no catch your information is
always kept safe plus has a special
bonus the u.s. CCA will give you ten
free chances to win a thousand bucks
when you test text in which is a pretty
awesome deal just think that could mean
10 chances to put towards something like
an ar-15 for free you heard me you can
pick up a brand-new ar-15 just by
texting the word win - 87 - - to the US
CCI wants to make sure if you're a law
abiding citizen that you have a chance
to own arms on top of your ten entries
to win the first 3,000 people to text in
will also be sent a free concealed carry
guide just for entering which means you
can find out how to better protect
yourself your loved ones your rights and
you might get a new gun the special
offer ends May 31st so don't wait text
win - 87 - 2 - and find out more get
your free guide us DC is a great
organization write educational materials
great legal materials text win - 87 - 2
- to get involved win - 87 - 2 - already
so the Democrats obviously are playing
this up to the hilt so now they're
playing the reverse which is we're
investigating Trump because Trump is
deeply corrupt and deeply evil also we
are magnanimous we want to get
infrastructure done that's a position
that Trump should have taken you should
have said Democrats are partisan hacks
also I still want to work with them to
get things done and if they refuse to
get things done that would be on them
the president looking magnanimous and
Democrats in Congress looking wild-eyed
should be what President Trump is
looking for in terms of a political
outcome instead I think he's sort of
achieved a little bit of the reverse
yesterday here's Chuck Schumer yesterday
the Senate Minority Leader saying we
believe in infrastructure we just but
President Trump is intransigent and mean
to watch what happened in the White
House would make your jaw drop we
Democrats believe in infrastructure and
despite signals in the previous few
weeks that he might not be serious we
went forward we came here very seriously
we were interested we are interested in
doing infrastructure it's clear the
president isn't he is looking for every
excuse okay so this is the typical
Democratic play here is that the
president doesn't want infrastructure
that he's walking away from the deal now
again I think the president probably
would love an infrastructure bill it
would be another thing that he can brag
about I'm not in favor of an
infrastructure bill I think a lot of
congressional Republicans aren't in
favor of spending trillions of dollars
on infrastructure concerns that are
generally not needed on the federal
level and can be handled appropriately
at the state level but again the angle
the Democrats have taken here is a smart
political angle here's Nancy Pelosi
shedding crocodile tears over all of
this after saying that the president
engaged in a cover-up deliberately
trying to provoke him into a blow-up and
then the blow-up happens then she says
no we went there with the spirit of
bipartisanship in our hearts ah she's
grating hopeful optimistic and seeing
the necessity for a big infrastructure
initiative for our country we went in
the spirit of bipartisanship to find
common ground with the President on this
just he came into the room made a
statement that he made was but I won't
even characterize it he just took a pass
and it just makes me wonder why why he
did that in any event I pray for the
President of the United States and I
pray for the United States of America
yeah I'm sure what a grave crisis we
have that we're not passing a crap
infrastructure bill with Nancy Pelosi's
help I pray for ya I'm sure that Nancy
gets on her knees every night and prays
for the president yeah I'm sure that's a
thing that's real and in a second I'm
gonna show you how cynical this play is
by Democrats because it actually is this
is a deeply cynical play by Democrats so
the same Nancy Pelosi
who's there saying we went to the White
House with the spirit of bipartisanship
five minutes after saying the president
was engaged in a cover-up without any
evidence that the president has covered
up illegal activity
then she got out there and she and she
ridiculed President Trump today was the
day he was supposed to tell us how what
he would be willing to
of support and pay-fors for all of that
instead in a an orchestrated almost to a
poor baby point-of-view
he came into the room and said that I
said that he was engaged in a cover-up
and he couldn't possibly couldn't
possibly engage in a conversation or an
infrastructure as long as as long as we
are investigating him and we thought we
had some level of agreement but you
never know but this president of united
states so that's what happened this
morning it was very very very strange
very strange because he's a strange man
he's volatile again this is what
Democrats were looking for and they got
it this was a cynical play by Democrats
and it happened to work I don't blame
the President on an emotional level for
doing what he did politically speaking
was it the smartest move probably not
again it gives it gives Democrats room
to run because the image that they are
trying to paint of President Trump is
that he is a volatile character Maxine
Waters is out there still prodding at
the president saying that Trump is gonna
back down in the end he's gonna back
down he's taking the strong position on
no negotiation with Democrats and he's a
coward so he'll back down
this is Democrats trying to troll Trump
now Trump is a master troll he is great
at getting under Democrat skin the
problem is that they are effectively
getting under his skin at this point
here's Maxine Waters trying to do just
that as I think about this threat that
he made today and I'm thinking about who
really benefits from infrastructure not
only will the citizens of this country
benefit if we're able to fix the roads
and the bridges and the waterways and
all of that but he's got a lot of
friends that I believe in construction
and development and who would also
benefit so he may have to back off of
that right so we want to do
infrastructure and he's just mean and
he's just girl now as they say the
Democrats here are incredibly cynical
they're incredibly cynical if President
Trump would have walked into the room
and said here's my infrastructure
package they would have walked out of
the room and they would have said we
can't negotiate with a corrupt evil
president that's what that's what would
have happened they would have said that
he's under investigation and we're not
gonna help him and then there would have
been no deal no deal is in the offing
the fact is that unlike the Republicans
under Newt Gingrich with Bill Clinton
who were willing to move to the
sensor with Bill Clinton on a variety of
topics ranging from glass-steagall to
welfare reform Democrats have been
absolutely unavailing in their
unwillingness to work with President
Trump they just are not willing to do it
they're looking for an excuse in other
words to beat up on presidents from
Stephen Colbert who is the it of the
Democratic Party at this point so much
comma dating I'm late-night television
here a Stephen Colbert yesterday mocking
President Trump for walking out
according to people in the room Trump
walked in didn't shake anyone's hand or
take a seat and left before anyone else
could speak all told it was over in
three minutes
according to stormy Daniels that's two
bonus minutes now Trump walked out the
door straight to the Rose Garden for a
nationally televised hissy fit complete
with a podium adorned with a pre-printed
sign that said no collusion no
obstruction so Trump has a clear stance
on infrastructure it's my way or no
highway okay this is the pitch the
Democrats are making now as I say this
is super cynical it's not the Democrats
are deeply invested in infrastructure
and it's not even the Democrats are
deeply invested in impeachment or
investigations they are invested in the
creation of an image about president
Trump so take Nancy Pelosi as an example
here is Nancy Pelosi yesterday saying
that maybe the president Trump is
impeachable maybe he ought to be
impeached here's the Speaker of the
House the fact is in plain sight in the
public domain this president is
obstructing justice and he's engaged in
a cover-up
and that could be an impeachable it's
not just the substance that we're after
we want to have to give the truth to the
American people but in striving to get
that the intervention that the that the
obstruction that the administration is
engaged in is some as they say the
cover-up is frequently worse than the
crime okay so she's admitting right
there there is no crime she's focusing
on obstruction which is not occurring by
the way there is no legal obstruction
that occurs when the executive branch
says we are not going to turn over
records to the to the legislative branch
that is not obstruction under any
possible definition of a
rushon of justice in criminal law and
Nancy Pelosi knows this so on the one
hand she wants to say the Trump is
impeachable on the other hand she says I
don't think we're gonna get any new
information from impeachment hearings
she's saying this stuff in the same
interview the press is just totally
obsessed with the impeachment part of it
not obsessed enough to write the
particulars of what we're doing in our
committees and how important that is but
just to say when are you going to do
that to your point I'm not sure that we
get any more information by instituting
an impeachment inquiry but if we thought
that we would that's a judgment we have
that we would have to make it's a
cynical play she's trying to create an
image of Trump she doesn't have the
stones to actually push impeachment
because Democrats don't want to push him
Pietschmann even Adam Schiff Adam Schiff
the president Trump has turned a pencil
Mike even Adam chef the congressman from
out here in California from my district
shift says listen we're not interested
in impeachment this is the guy who went
on TV every night for two years and
claimed that President Trump was a cat's
paw for the Russians here's the atom
chef I do think that that
notwithstanding all of that that there
is a valid argument to be made that if
you fail to bring an impeachment even
knowing it would be unsuccessful but if
you fail to bring an impeachment what
does that say about this president's
conduct and whether he is fit for office
and so I do think that that has to be
weighed though against the the other
concern which is what does an acquittal
say because then you have a an
adjudication that this conduct is not an
impeachable offense okay so in other
words we don't want to impeach we just
want to paint a picture in front was a
bad guy but we don't want him peach
james Clyburn who's the House Majority
Whip he came forth he said a majority of
Democrats are not in favor of
impeachment a majority of Democrats so
this is all just a cynical game it's a
cynical game and what President Trump
should do is he should point out it's a
cynical game they don't want to impeach
me these investigations are all a
partisan misdirect and I am focused on
the business of the American people
which is why I'm even sitting here with
people who insult me to my face every
single day right that would have been
the best move for him yesterday as
opposed to the storming out and the Rose
Garden press
conference and all the rest of it here's
Jim's Clyburn saying just this how many
Democrats in your caucus do you think
would support the opening of an
impeachment inquiry well first of all
thank you so much for having me
the vast majority would in fact support
impeachment just not now
the issue now is whether or not there
there's something that should be done
today or tomorrow or whether or not we
go through a process by which we build a
foundation upon which to successfully
impeach no that's a no so Democrats are
not interested in impeachment cuz they
can read the polls just like everybody
else can but they are interested in and
making it seem like the president is
impeachable without natural offense in
just a second I want to talk about why
Democrats are playing this game as
opposed to you know playing the policy
game but first let's talk about
something we can all agree on saving
money the reality is if you're not
shopping around you're probably not
saving money so what if there was a way
for somebody to do the shopping around
for you well that's exactly what honey
does honey is a free tool that you
download to your computer's browser
while you shop online honey scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts and then it automatically
applies the coupon with the biggest
savings to your cart a checkout just
like magic it takes zero effort to
install just two clicks you are ready to
start saving any time you shop online
there's really no reason not to use
honey it's free to use easy to install
on your computer in just two clicks
don't take it from me take it from our
listeners get honey for free at join
honey calm slash pen that is join honey
calm slash patent honey it's the smart
shopping assistance it saves you time
money I use honey all the time I've got
it running in the background of my
computer I shop at Amazon like all the
time and honey has saved me an untold
amount of money it's great I mean you
literally do nothing and then it saves
you money by applying all the the coupon
codes that it can find go to join honey
calm slash bun that is join honey calm
slash pen there's no reason to miss out
on saving money join honey calm slash
man go check them out right now so the
reason that Democrats are focused like a
laser beam on creating this image of
President Trump is because on policy
they are far too radical for the
American people
yesterday was replete with examples of
this so there's one Democrat who
actually had her portion of the
Congressional Record wiped out like they
actually went out and they struck this I
believe from the Congressional Record
her name is Underwood this particular
representative and she was confronting
DHS the Department of Homeland Security
and CBP the Border Patrol and she
accused them of wanting children
crossing the border to die she's
accusing members of the US government
who are tasked with keeping Americans
safe of wanting and purposely killing
migrant children it's an amazing amazing
clip people keep dying and so this is
obviously more than a question of
resources but at this point with five
kids that have died 5,000 separated from
their families
I feel like and the evidence is really
clear that this is intentional
it's intentional it's a policy choice
being made on purpose by this
administration and it's cruel and
inhumane
that's an Impala accusation ban our men
and women fight hard to protect people
in our custody every single day it is an
appalling accusation this is the face
that Democrats want to present this is
where President Trump should be putting
his focus not on the investigations not
on the impeachment stuff it's going
nowhere the media will run with it but
it's done no significant damage to Trump
his approval ratings have been almost
exactly the same for his entire
presidency
they've always been between 40 and 44
percent occasionally they rise above
that but the reality is that he has been
extraordinarily stable in terms of what
people think of him what is not stable
is what people think of Democrats how is
the administration not already running
with this with an ad of this lady saying
this within it with an ad showing people
crossing the border illegally in Tijuana
trying to rush that border and then this
lady saying that CBP are a bunch of of
cruel inhumane for trying to kill
migrant children that by there was
representative Lauren Underwood of
Illinois when and the person she's
speaking to his homeland security
secretary Kevin miquelina it's a that is
such an astonishing an evil statement by
her now this is intentional that CBP is
trying to kill these kids it's absurd
you know he's denying beds for the kids
by the way it's Democrats President
Trump in the Trump administration have
been asking the New York Times itself
said that Democrats should go along with
this the editorial board Republicans
have been asking for more beds more
funding for facilities along the border
and Democrats have been turning that
down instead people are being housed in
in not great conditions specifically
because they don't have the funding that
is necessary thanks to Democratic
intransigence
and all the migrants who are dying the
five migrant deaths she's talking about
these are kids who are being brought in
who haven't been fed in three days
haven't had any water and by the time
they reach CBP it's too late for CBP to
do anything by and large that is what is
happening here it's not CBP throwing
kids into cages and then starving them
to death what a despicable evil
statement no president Trump has
something to run on here this is the
stuff President Trump can be running on
actual policy not all of this talk about
it but I understand listen if it were me
and I were under attack all day by the
Democrats any human being would want to
fight back against that the way the
President Trump is fighting back yeah
really I truly believe this any human
being who's under the sort of assault
the president Trump is right now would
be just as angry as president Trump is
if you believe you were innocent hey but
that is not what he's gonna make his
political hey he's going to win
political victory on the back of
Democrats being extraordinarily extreme
Katie Pavlich has an article over at
townhall today talking about murders by
ms-13 she's - illegal aliens one who
came to the United States and 2015 as
part of a family unit and the other
unaccompanied in 2016 released by the
Prince George's County Police Department
after being charged with attempted
first-degree murder and other crimes
upon release they then killed 14 year
old girl Ariana Fuentes Diaz and dumped
her body in a creek Prince George's
County which contains Baltimore is a
sanctuary for illegal aliens both are
members of the extremely violent gang
ms-13 ice released a statement they said
following the recent arrest of two
unlawfully present teens suspected in
the violent murder of a young girl in
Maryland ice officers in Baltimore are
again seeking to take custody of the
illegal aliens through the ice detainer
process following the Prince George's
County Detention Center failure to
cooperate in other words Baltimore
refused to basically turn these folks
over under an ice detainer request the
it that is what President Trump should
be running on and Democrats
simultaneously claiming that our border
patrol officers who are risking life and
limb to protect the country every day
that those border patrol officers are
actually emissaries of evil who wish to
kill children seems to me that would be
worth running on or maybe you run
against the Democrats on abortion Nancy
Pelosi basically just suggested that
anyone who is pro-life is a white man
who fears a woman speaker
the House Nancy Pelosi you know our
wonderful moderate Speaker of the House
who just wants to get infrastructure
done for the good of the people and
prays for President Trump and the
country every night here's what she
thinks of white guys this is about lack
of respect for women this is about some
fear that is in our community our
society about women having the the
ability to have the size and timing of
their families working with their
husbands with their doctors with their
God whatever it is when you see them
lined up for of the house guys guys guys
God just white guys guys signing for
their discharge petition in a way that
is it really it doesn't even represent
the truth of what they are they're white
guys who fear women that's that's the
case the Democrats want to make Trumpkin
certainly run against that or how about
illa hen Omar he beloved representative
who appeared on the cover of Rolling
Stone with Nancy Pelosi and who has
spent a vast bevy of her time in
Congress
rebutting allegations of anti-semitism
because she keeps saying unfortunate
jew-hating things
here's Ilhan Omar attacking every
conservative in America by suggesting
that if you are pro-life it's because
you're actually a secret religious
fanatic who wants to keep women under
your thumb it's coming from illa hon
Omar okay here she says let's just be
honest for the religious right this
isn't simply about their care or concern
for life if they cared about or we're
concerned about children they would be
concerned about the children that are
being detained and those that are dying
in camps across our borders or the
children who are linguish endure and
facing homelessness so it's that
pro-life people don't actually care
about children they're just Christian
fanatics they're evil they're evil that
President Trump has such a great thing
to run on his economic record and such a
great thing to run against Nancy Pelosi
and Ilhan Omar and representative
Underwood he has he has a lot to run
against what he can't
is get distracted by what Democrats are
trying to distract him with to make him
appear volatile to to play to his worst
instincts and that is all the
investigation kind of stuff now again I
have emotional sympathy for the
president I'll explain why I have an
emotional sympathy not only for the
president's aunt on this but also for a
lot of Republicans who say yeah I'm glad
president Trump is just punching bag but
I'll explain in just a second first what
if buying a house was like buying a
timeshare
you show up with a herd of other people
that also wanted the free gift and then
you're in a pressure cooker sales
presentation for 90 minutes or three
hours you don't have the opportunity to
have your real estate agent
professionally negotiate the price
there's no inspector to uncover hidden
problems no loan officer to explain
every detail of the loan terms interest
rate fees payment schedule total cost
folks you wouldn't buy a home this way
that's exactly how the majority of time
shares are sold if you are stuck in a
timeshare if you called the resort they
won't let you out if you've tried
selling it and you can't call timeshare
exit team they will fight for you I
trust them I know the folks who founded
it you can trust them to text Ben to 79
79 79 for a free consultation that is B
en to 79 79 79 a lot of these time
shares man you are stuck there you paid
like 20,000 bucks for a week and then
you have annual upkeep fees and you
can't use it many of the weeks that you
want it and then you can't get rid of it
because these things are on like it's
impossible to sell them you need to talk
to my friends at times your exit team
text my name Ben - 79 79 79 for that
free consultation there's no reason why
you should continue to suffer under this
particular burden message and data rates
may apply the folks at I'm sure exit
team have helped over 16,000 people get
out of their time shares they can help
you as well
text Ben to 79 79 79 for that free
consultation and here's the good news I
mean if you if they can't do anything
for you they're not gonna charge you
text Ben - 79 79 79 for that free
consultation okay I want to get to sort
of the emotional reason why many
Republicans are fine with President
Trump punching back at Democrats on
impeachment and on all the rest of this
in just one second first you should go
over and subscribe over at daily
wire.com for $9.99 a month you get the
rest of this show you get two additional
hours of the show every day you also get
our Sunday special on Saturdays our
Sunday special this week features former
Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich
here's a little bit what that sounded
like
we are imperfect but compared to any
other society I'm aware of we have a
stronger system of freedom a greater
capacity for people to rise and a
greater awareness that anybody can come
from anywhere and become an American the
conversation with speaker Gingrich is
really good it covers an enormous amount
of ground we talk about everything from
President Trump's record to his
possibilities of reelection we talk
about Newt Gingrich's own record and
Speaker of the house when impeachment is
appropriate when impeachment is not
appropriate it really gets into some
deep water so you're gonna want to check
that out when you subscribe you get that
on Saturday as opposed to Sunday and you
get our extra questions behind the
paywall which is pretty awesome also
when you get the annual subscription you
get this the very greatest and beverage
vessels the leftist cheers hot or cold
tumbler go check that out right now it
is indeed spectacular and we'll fill you
with just a certain sense of emotional
fulfillment and joy that I'm not sure
that you can get anywhere else maybe you
can but not from us in any case if you
want to work here there's also an
opportunity for you to do that
our business is growing rapidly that
means we are excited to be offering more
opportunities to become part of our
in-house team head on over to daily wire
comm slash careers see if any of our job
openings would be right for you or
someone you know we are expanding
quickly then we have a lot of great jobs
available if you want to work for the
show go over to daily wire comm slash
careers next thing you know you might be
working out here in beautiful sunny Los
Angeles with all of the glitz and
paparazzi I mean man what a lifestyle it
is slaving away for my show four hours a
day in a dark dingy room well that's
great well I think I'm not selling this
right okay go go over to daily wear
couriers and go check it out if you're
interested in working here also please
subscribe to YouTube and iTunes please
leave a review it always helps us we are
the fastest growing and largeness
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so one of the reasons I think that a lot
of Republicans are sympathetic to
president Trump's emotional response to
Democrats is because on an emotional
level it's very much justified
Republicans look at Democrats and they
say these people have been getting away
with in the case of Ted Kennedy actual
murder for years or at least
manslaughter for years Democrats have
been getting away with this stuff in the
face of the press without any serious
blowback
without any serious long-term
repercussions for years Democrats have
been deeply dishonest about a lot of
this stuff
Democrats have promoted some of the
worst people in America and then have
paid no political price for that
meanwhile they're spending all their
time creating the impression that Trump
is impeachable when again they have not
provided evidence of any impeachable
offense that the president has committed
he may not like what the president did I
don't like a lot of the things that are
reported in the Moller report I think he
looks like he's volatile I think that he
looks like he is not stable when it
comes to his handling of his own
administration you know all of that may
be true but the Democrats have provided
no evidence of impeachable offense so if
you're Trump or you're a trump supporter
and you look at this you say of course
he's reacting like this he's a human
being and again I'm an emotional level I
think that's correct it's hard not to
look at what has happened with Michael
avenatti for example and not feel like
president Trump should be able to punch
whomever he pleases in the media and
among Democrats
Michael avenatti was arrested yesterday
is charged again by the feds this time
he was charged with forging stormy
Daniels his signature to steal $300,000
from her so it turns out that President
Trump wasn't the only famous man to
screw stormy Daniels apparently Michael
avenatti has now been charged with fraud
and aggravated identity theft for
allegedly snatching a total of 300 grand
from stormy Daniels and spending it on
personal expenses like airfare hotel's
restaurant delivery and to bankroll his
law firm federal prosecutors in New York
announced the latest charges against the
Newport Beach litigator soon after ABC
News reported that avenatti was expected
to be charged with additional financial
crimes the 48 year old lawyer faces a
slew of charges on both coasts including
wire fraud bank fraud and extortion on
Wednesday a grand jury also indicted a
vinay for trying to extort the footwear
giant Nike to the tune of 25 million
bucks what does this have to do with
Trump and Republicans reacting in
rageful fashion to Democrat allegations
of impeachable offenses well when you
watch how
Media treated avenatti for years knowing
that the dude was a corrupt sleazebag
it's pretty astonishing the Washington
free beacon put together this particular
this particular montage of famous media
figures praising Michael avenatti is the
savior of the Republic
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare
Michael joining us once again is Michael
Aven audience bringing Michael avenatti
Michael avenatti
Michael avenatti Michael avenatti thank
you very much he's out there saving the
country says he may be the savior of the
Republic if you are something of a folk
hero now Michael avenatti an apology
I've been saying I'm not for reading
Michael I've seen you everywhere what do
you love to say I was wrong brother
you have a lot to say I am just dying to
hear what you think okay so this is how
the media treated avenatti for years and
Republicans rightly say okay and now you
guys are going to be the moral
conscience of the nation these are the
same Democrats who still have not
actually demanded the governor Ralph
Northam of Virginia resigned over his
blackface photo from 1985 medical school
yearbook now I by the way opposed him
resigning for that because I think that
people do change over time I think that
you have to look at the totality of how
people act over the course of their life
but northern handled this thing
incredibly badly you'll remember that
after that blackface photo emerged
originally northern originally
acknowledged it was him in the photo and
then apologized my fellow Virginians
earlier today I released a statement
apologizing for behavior in my past that
falls far short of the standard you set
for me when you elected me to be your
governor I believe you deserve to hear
directly from me that photo and the
racist and offensive attitudes that
represents does not reflect that person
I am today or the way that I have
conducted myself as a soldier a doctor
and a public servant I'm deeply sorry
okay he said that yesterday
investigators in Virginia came out with
a report what did the report phat fine
well it found that they couldn't
identify whether it was him in the
yearbook well he already admitted it was
him in the yearbook and then he
backtracked it and said well maybe it
wasn't me maybe I'll send another
blackface photo but not that blackface
photo of course they can't identify him
in the photo it's impossible to identify
from the photo the pixelation sucks one
of the people in the photo is wearing a
KKK hat he can't identify what his face
looks like under the KKK hat from a
photo from 1985 nonetheless they did a
full-scale investigation in Virginia and
voila came up with nothing - the
photograph on governor Northam personal
page depicting an individual in
blackface and an individual in KKK robes
we could not conclusively determine the
identity of either individual depicted
in that photograph the governor himself
has made inconsistent public statements
in this regard
no individual that we interviewed has
told us from personal knowledge that the
governor is in that photograph and no
individual with knowledge has come
forward to us to report that the
governor is in the photograph well I
guess that northern was okay now
Republicans look at this stuff and they
tear their hair up they say ok where
where's the media attention on the fact
that Ralph Northam admitted he was there
and then launched an investigation to
find that he was not maybe there and yet
he still governor Virginia no problem
everybody no fuss no muss everything's
great how is that even a possibility how
is it the media that that trotted out
Michael avenatti to the tune of probably
hundreds of millions of dollars in free
media coverage how is it that that media
still has credibility when talking about
the morality of President Trump again
when there are no serious allegations of
impeachable offenses that have been put
forward at this time
you understand why Trump is reacting the
way he is that doesn't mean it's
necessarily the smartest move for him to
react the way that he is okay meanwhile
Democrats are moving in defense of
Elizabeth Warren Warren has been gaining
in the polls there's some really
interesting polls that show that Warren
is picking up a lot of Bernie Sanders is
support that Sanders is starting to flag
that he's starting to fade a little bit
and that Elizabeth Warren who schtick is
that she has a plan for everything which
doesn't mean that she has a good plan
for everything Stalin had a seven-year
plan also and she she has a plan for
everything
well that's starting to pick up some
ground among progressives but there's an
article today in The Washington Post
about how much money Elizabeth Warren
was pulling down while she was a lawyer
apparently she's charged as much as 675
bucks an hour which seems like a pretty
solid fee I mean that's a
ship fee at a major law firm 675 bucks
an hour to advise a variety of clients
from people with asbestos disease to a
corporation facing possible liability of
a ruptured breast implants she consulted
for more than a dozen committees
representing claimants and creditors in
many cases she worked for a number of
corporate clients she advised the former
directors of Getty oil during Texaco's
bankruptcy will get e oil working for
the oil companies she served as an
expert witness for the fuller Austin
insulation company in a case against
insurers she actually served for Dow
Chemical which she advised in the
mid-1990s Dow Chemicals denied that it
played a role in designing or making
breast implants that allegedly created
claims for women in this case according
to according to her list of cases says
Elizabeth served as consultant to ensure
adequate compensation for women who
claimed injury from silicone breast
implants who otherwise may not have
received anything Wenzhou Chemical filed
for bankruptcy thanks to in part to
Elizabeth's efforts Alcorn and created a
2.35 billion dollar fund to compensate
women claiming injury from Dow Corning
Corning's silicone breast implants but
she did work for Dow Chemical in that
bankruptcy process
she worked in some 50 odd cases she was
taking on outside legal work as early as
1991 and then that work picked up as
soon as she joined the faculty at
Harvard Law School what's hilarious is
that she's pulling down all this Kwan
and suddenly you have a OC defending all
of us so a OC tweeted out today breaking
news lady had a job got paid more than
me
nice work now to the amount of Wall
Street big pharma and fossil fuel money
presidential candidates accepted over
their careers and how much they're
taking now so I'm confused if you took
money from Dow Chemical if you're
Republican there's no doubt aoc would be
talking about how evil this person is
but it's Elizabeth Warren so the
headline is according to AOC lady had a
job got paid more than me which is
reminiscent to when Bernie Sanders said
sure I made a million bucks
I wrote a best-selling book funny how
the principles of capitalism suddenly
are inoffensive when they benefit people
that aoc happens to like okay in other
news I do want to talk about this this
Quentin Tarantino thing so Quentin
Tarantino is obviously this this very
famous film maker he's made about
of huge hits from Kill Bill to pulp
fiction
I happened not to be a huge fan of
Quentin Tarantino I think that he has an
a unique talent for putting together
great scenes and an inability to put
together great movies this is sort of my
take on Tarantino's that he has these
scenes that are embedded in movies that
I don't love all together but the scenes
themselves are really terrific he's
almost a YouTube filmmaker it's like
watching a series of really great
YouTube videos that don't necessarily
hold together as an overarching plot in
any case that's my artistic critique of
Tarantino but turns he no handles
himself with the press I think in a
perfectly appropriate fashion he took a
shellacking yesterday publicly why well
he was asked about the fact that one of
the that margot robbie who is a pretty
good actress stars as Sharon Tate in his
new movie Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
stars Brad Pitt Leonardo DiCaprio and
Leonardo DiCaprio among others well
Tarantino was asked by a reporter
why Margot Robbie didn't have it more
speaking lines the implication being
that he's a sexist from not allowing
Margot Robbie more speaking lines now
this is an incredibly silly allegation a
Kill Bill which has two volumes with
Huma Thurman the main character is not
only a woman she's a woman who proceeds
to slaughter about half a dozen men per
movie there there are other powerful
female characters Lucy Liu stars is a
powerful female character in Kill Bill
there are powerful female care in Pulp
Fiction uma Thurman also plays a key
role in that film also the basic idea
that in film the most important
characters are the ones who speak the
most is simply not true Godzilla doesn't
have tons of lines in the movie Godzilla
there are lots and lots of great
characters in the history of film who
actually do not speak all that much very
often it's peripheral characters who do
a lot of the speaking or characters who
are main but have to drive the narrative
forward but they aren't actually the the
villain or the main character or
anything like that
it's a typical trope of film this this
silly notion that women have to speak
most on film in order for the film to be
not sexist as stupid and so Tarantino
just refuses to take the question he
just basically says this is a bunch of
nonsense I'm not gonna play this game
Quentin you have put margot robbie a
very talented actress actor in your
films she was in the Leonardo with
Leonardo in wolf of wallstreet i tania
the
is a you know person with a great deal
of acting talent and yet you haven't
really given her many lines in the movie
and I wondered I guess that was a
deliberate choice on your part and I
just wanted to know why that was that we
don't hear her actually speaking very
much and Margo I wanted you to also
comment about being in the film in this
part well I just reject your hypotheses
good for him good for him
this is not any a Margot Robbie's
laughing at it because she knows it's
stupid too and she knows it's idiotic
and then she in Margot Robbie proceeds
to defend Tarantino she says I think the
moment I got on screen gave an
opportunity to honor Sharon and her
lightness I don't think it was intended
to delve deeper as Brad mentioned I
think the tragedy was ultimately the
loss of innocence and to show those
wonderful sides of her could be done
quickly without speaking and I did feel
like I had a lot of time to explore the
character even without dialogue right
because that's how movies work we live
in such a stupid culture that if we do
not have exact parity in every aspect of
life then we don't have overall parity
this is the the mistaking of equality
for sameness equality is not sameness my
wife and I are equal we are not the same
my wife does things that I don't do and
I do things that my wife doesn't do and
when it comes to film some of the most
powerful female characters in film
history do not have tons of lines some
of the most powerful male stars in film
history do not have tons of lines screen
time isn't even a good proxy for the
power of a character on film the fact
though that we are now dumbing down film
to questions like this the death of art
comes when political correctness
suggests that we have to set basic
metrics as to what characters ought to
and ought not to do it's pretty amazing
we basically say in in Hollywood in the
1930s there was something called the
Hays Code the Hays Code was voluntarily
adopted code by Hollywood that was
attempting to get rid of a lot of the
more morally objectionable material in
Hollywood the Catholic Legion of decency
was basically threatening boycotts
against a lot of the movies so Hollywood
adopted the Hays Code
we've now adopted a new political
correctness code a new political
correctness code that is designed to
shape movies in the least artistic
possible way not in alignment with the
common morality of the time but in
alignment with woek sensibilities and if
we don't have a certain number of gay
characters or a certain number of
black characters are a certain number of
lines for women the movie is therefore
unfit for showing you want to make a
worse artistic world is a pretty easy
way to do it okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like there's actually
believe it or not a really good article
in The New York Times today all about
China using high-tech surveillance to
subdue minorities one of the things
that's been very disquieting over the
past yeah well really the past century
is the willingness of a lot of folks on
the left to give all sorts of kudos to
authoritarian regimes that they think
reflect their general economic values
without reference to all the evil things
that these regimes do in order to
promote those economic values so the New
York Times famously defended Stalin in
the middle of the Ukrainian famine the
the media famously names Time magazine
famously put enough Hitler on their
covers Man of the Year in 1936 there's
always been this warmth on the part of
some people on the left toward regimes
that are authoritarian as long as they
get things done Thomas Friedman wrote a
column a few years back about how maybe
a one-party authoritarian state in China
is less dangerous than America's
political system is really an absurd
column well today the New York Times has
an actual good piece and that piece
talks about how China is subduing
minorities say a God's eye view of
kashgar an ancient city in western China
flashed on to a wall wall sized screen
with colorful icons marking police
stations checkpoints and locations of
recent security incidents at the click
of a mouse a technician explained the
police can pull up live video from any
surveillance camera or take a closer
look at anyone passing than one of the
thousands of checkpoints in the city to
demonstrate she showed how the system
could retrieve the photo home address
and official identification of a woman
who had been stopped at a checkpoint on
a major highway the simulation presented
in an industry fair in China offered a
rare look at a system that now peers
into nearly every corner of Xinjiang the
trouble region where Kosh car is located
this is the vision of hi-tech
surveillance precise all-seeing
infallible that China's leaders are
investing billions of dollars in every
year the fact is that that China is
using this system to target millions of
their called Euler's I believe that my
pronunciation is not great and members
of other Muslim ethnic groups in
Xinjiang
treating a city like a battlefield the
platform was designed to apply the ideas
of military cyber systems to civilian
public security the system taps into the
networks of neighborhood informants
tracks individuals analyzes their
behavior tries to anticipate potential
crime protests of violence and then
recommends which Security Forces to
deploy you want to know how China is
able to to centralize Authority this is
how they centralized Authority by the
way China also is violating every
environmental rule known to man all the
folks in the West we're complaining
about the West being a terrible place
for the environment article today from
the UK Daily Mail China has spewed out
7,000 tons of a banned chemical since
2013 a shocking study has found the
emissions from northeastern China
contributed between 40 and 60% to a
global rise in CFC emissions CFC are
floral carbons I believe
chlorofluorocarbons thank you the source
of the current increase in
chlorofluorocarbon 11 is unknown
scientists suggest it may originate from
newly made insulation and cooling units
global spikes in the emissions were
traced to East Asia last year the worst
offending regions remained unconformity
--tz-- on every agreement that it has
sign China centralizes Authority and
targets political opponents in an
apartheid like way and yet so many
people are willing to overlook all of
that and pretend that the United States
is the bad guy when it comes to world
conflicts you'll read a book take a look
around the world before you go there
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate okay thing that I hate number one
so governor Greg Abbott of Texas has now
signed into law a bill that effectively
protects companies like chick-fil-a and
the idea is that there are a bunch of
locations all around the country that
have decided that they are going to
prevent chick-fil-a from actually coming
into their communities on the basis of
the fact that the owner of chick-fil-a
happens to be Pro traditional marriage
so governor Abbott signed a bill or he's
preparing to sign legislation that is a
defense of chick-fil-a and religious
freedom saying that if the owner decides
on religious principles that does not
mean that you can ban his company the
bill was fast-tracked in the GOP
controlled legislature Republicans have
prohibited cities from taking adverse
action against an individual based on
contributions to religious organizations
so how did NBC headline this obvious
bill that is designed to protect First
Amendment freedoms how did exactly did
they do that here's the headline Texas
governor Greg Abbott has signaled he'll
sign the controversial bill which
critics say is discrimination cloaked in
religion because this is how the
mainstream media treats conservative
legislation when it's pro-life
legislation they run headlines that say
things like signs of that support for
pro-life legislation critics say is
secretly designed to keep women down
well that's what they're doing here -
Greg Abbott signs a bill that is
designed to prevent religious
discrimination and NBC News's headline
is critics say is discrimination cloaked
in religion they would never do this
about any democratic bill ever it's
pretty obvious what the media are doing
and it's pretty terrible other things
that I hate so an NYU graduation speaker
got up over the weekend his name is
Stephen Williams rash the doctoral
graduate and in his speech he decided to
endorse BDS and call President Trump a
fascist which is pretty astonishing BDS
is a is a an anti-semitic tactic that is
designed by actual terrorist groups in
order to undercut Israel's economic
system it is designed by fascists to
forward the interests of fascists and he
calls President Trump a fascist
here is Steven William thrash at NYU in
by the way has any conservative spoken
at a graduation like ever in the United
States the percentages are always minut
it's always like two or three and
there's a massive remember when I
graduated from UCLA when I graduated
from UCLA our speaker was mayor Antonio
Villaraigosa who was a Democrat
politician Laura Bush was scheduled to
speak at the Business School Laura Bush
one of the most inoffensive people ever
the business school protest and
rescinded the invitation but you'll get
crap like this in NYU graduation many of
us have been together Occupy Wall Street
and at black lives matter protest and at
marches against that fascist in the
White House that would not allow 56
different countries to cross borders and
be together in a setting like this and I
am so proud so proud of NYU's chapters
of students for justice in Palestine and
you
voices for peace and of gsok and of the
nyu student government and of my
colleagues in the department of social
and cultural analysis for supporting the
boycott divestment and sanctions
movement against the apartheid state
government in Israel because this is
what we are called to do this is our NYU
legacy if your NYU legacy is supporting
a terrorist driven program that is
designed to destroy the only democracy
in the Middle East then you know that
let me just say that your moral
sensibility has been completely
destroyed the same thing is happening by
the way over at UCLA UCLA hosts these
radical anti-israel conferences that do
in fact cross over into anti-semitism
it's unfortunate our university systems
as my friend Dennis Prager says they may
have knowledge but they lack wisdom and
that is obvious every single day all
right we will be back here later today
with two additional hours of the Ben
Shapiro show so go subscribe of the rest
will see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
British prime minister Theresa May is on
the rocks a Catholic Cardinal calls to
hold off Islamic immigration to the West
and president Trump's administration
admits it has barely built any wall what
will it mean for 2020 and will president
Trump face the same fate as Theresa May
we will analyze check it out at the
Michael Knowles show